I'm waiting for your makeup line
patiently I'm trying to manifest it
quickly I'm also trying to manifest this
Tony Tony World Tour - please try that
was news to me just as it much was to
you I was like oh my god a tour is
happening someone call me what would it
take though to get it to happen you know
what
everybody's like supportive of each
other is like you know personal like
ventures right now and if it were to
happen I would want it to be a surprise
you know what I mean I feel like we know
so much now you know what I mean I feel
like your news is right at your
fingertips and sometimes it's very bad
journalism
shame on you whoever recorded that so if
it's gonna happen you're just gonna drop
it as a surprise for us I mean I'm not
gonna go that far because then you're
gonna take that blurb and put it right
there so that's not fair I love you
happy beautycon a I'm you know I'm gonna
keep manna-fest again I'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed thank you so much you
too
[Music]